what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar back at it again with the
latest craziest developments in the one
piece story
and wow what insane happenings
took place in this one the worst
generation versus the yonko fight has
never been this interesting so make sure
to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming
the best thing you could do is smash
that like button until it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one piece videos
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop which will be
next week feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist which
includes videos about all yonko
supernova warlords and much more link to
that
is in the description now without
further ado let's jump
into it this week's shonen jump cover is
starring luffy
as we're told the winds of adventure
propel him forward i love the way that's
worded we're also told the war
approaches its climax and as we know
as we approach the climax things will
keep getting crazier and crazier
and this chapter definitely did not
disappoint so we start with orochi
and the fire he started and orochi runs
into the red scabbards of all people
who didn't even know about his demise
earlier in the day this is perfect
because if kaido would have killed him
then toki's prophecy and the whole idea
of the nine scabbards exacting revenge
on orochi and odin's name would not have
been quite as fulfilling but
now orochi back from the dead faces the
ghosts he so
feared and he's freaking out and we love
to see it
fukurokuju orochi's ninja henchman is
here too
and offers to handle the scabbards which
we all know wouldn't work
but hey the dude's pretty brave you
gotta give him that orochi's reasoning
for not running is interesting
he'd be surrounded plus kaido has
wounded the red scabbard so this is his
best bet
to take them out right now and stuck
between kaido and the red scabbards it's
not that crazy that he decided to take
his chances with the scabbards but he
definitely underestimated them orochi
mentions kanjuro which must infuriate
the scabbards all the more and i love
seeing how nervous and sweating he is
compared to the stoic faces of the
scabbards who honestly view him more as
an inconvenience than their goal
which is pretty much the ultimate insult
anyway this is it
orochi transforms into the 8 headed
serpent and from the looks
of it together the scabbards managed to
cut all the heads at the same time
what sweet revenge especially because
after they cut all his heads off
denjiro says we don't have time to waste
on the likes of you
again i'm not certain how the mythical
zone fruit works but it would make much
more sense for this to be orochi's end
than the kaido moment because now this
part of the prophecy has been fulfilled
and because he transformed they managed
to get
all the heads rather than just one it's
a nice needed moment for the scabbards
showing that this wasn't for nothing
and they've already made progress
towards their goal it also seems like a
fitting
not to mention hilarious and for orochi
to come back from the dead as if he's
going to make some big and dramatic
difference
only to be sent off again just as
quickly by the so-called ghosts that
haunted his thoughts for
20 years and then we get an interesting
ninja showdown set up between rhizo and
fukurokuju as they both continue
to show devotion to their so-called dead
fools
orochi and odin respectively fukurokuju
says they were fated to clash and so we
get the setup for a potentially
naruto-esque fight
where we'll get to see some fun ninja
techniques
this is definitely a matchup that makes
a lot of sense but it's hard to believe
how many matchups
oda has created in this war honestly
i can't see this arc being over anytime
soon with everything that still needs to
be wrapped up
then we jump to the most hyped part of
this chapter
and it's mind-blowing stuff guys we
joined the main event on the roof big
mom suggests a combined attack with
kaido
and we all freak out on the inside how
hype is that
a yonko combo move big mom hypes the
power of this attack even more by saying
and i quote i wonder how many of the
five will survive
end quote remember the goal was to
divide and conquer the supernova
want to separate the yonko but lost says
he can't send one of them away because
their haki is too strong
that makes sense and it's nice to get
that explanation from la himself so then
kid decides fine
we'll have to just tear them apart the
old-fashioned way the yonko prepared to
launch their combined attack and i
absolutely
love how they're trash talking each
other during the process kaido calling
her an old hag and big mom calling him a
brat
when zorro sees this combo attack he
says and i quote this is
insane and quote as if he's coming up
with the title for one of my one piece
chapter reviews
they won't be able to dodge so what
happens
and this is one of the craziest most
epic parts in the chapter
are boyz it completely sparing the
others from the
impact big mom wondered how many would
die and one supernova not even a captain
managed to block the attack without even
dying
wow zorro is just so
damn awesome however luffy won't let
zoro take all the glory and goes in to
attack kaido suddenly
allowing them to accomplish what they
wanted to to separate
big mom from kaido again i keep
mentioning this in the reviews but you
can really see
luffy standing out when compared to the
others as they are all
left to fight big mom together luffy
takes on the strongest creature on his
own it's not a 3-2 split but a 4-1
split which reinforces why luffy will be
the pirate king when compared to the
other epically cool worst generation
pirates
i love luffy's trash talk too kaido
dodges one of his moves and luffy is
loving it he smiles asking kaido why
he's dodging before suggesting that it's
because
it would hurt the dude is having so much
fun as he fights the strongest creature
in the world
however luffy does pay for taking on
kaido by himself and kaido unleashes
powerful combos
and finishes it off with three realms
ragnarok which looks destructive and
damaging af
i wouldn't be too worried about luffy
even if it looks bad
sure kaido is winning but luffy is
succeeding in distracting him
giving the others a better chance to
deal with big mom and oh boy
do they deal with big mom although law
can't transport big mom using his powers
he can transport her homies he traps
zeus in a cube kid created
then another testament to the sheer
legendariness of zorro he is not only up
after taking that block
he goes on to cut prometheus sending big
mom falling to the ground
even though i'm already such a zorro
fanboy i continue to be blown away by
him
time after time it's nice seeing killer
play a part 2
as he chases napoleon after separating
big mom from her homies
they have a better chance but big mom
just thinks it's silly that they think
getting rid of them the homies would
make a difference
but they are counting on strategy rather
than strength kid shines here and i've
been waiting for this moment
he takes a punch from big mom but
manages to use his powers after grabbing
big mom with his metal arm to repel her
high up in the air
la proceeds to send a giant boulder at
her
which sends her flying big mom is not
amused that will only slow her down a
bit
but do no real damage however what she
doesn't realize until it's too late
is that she's been pushed right off the
flying island big mom is panicking big
time as she drops while there's nothing
but ocean below
she's crying out for zeus's help but
he's trapped and he can't help
they tell her it's time for her to drop
out and as a cultured man who
appreciates puns
i gotta say nice one zorro seems in pain
but they appear to have done it they
appear
to have found a way to defeat a yonko as
far as this fight is concerned now is it
possible
and even probable that big mom will be
saved in some way whether by kaido or
someone else
yeah totally but that should not take
away from the epicness of this
effort these guys did a great job here
and if by some chance
all five get some time to team up
against kaido
that would definitely increase their
chances a lot remains to be seen
like how hurt exactly are luffy and
zorro
but i'm pretty confident it's usual
shonen injuries that won't actually mean
too much
in the long run even if they look bad
whatever happens this was the best
chapter in a while and the most hyped
and exciting one for me personally
i cannot wait for next week as usual let
me know your thoughts
on this chapter and what you look
forward to seeing the most in the next
one
if you do enjoy these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you can do is smash that like
button until it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell
and select all or you will miss future
one piece videos
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop which
will be next week feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist which
includes videos on all yonko
supernova warlords and much more link to
that
is in the description and i especially
want to thank the patron squad over on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord wigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grata acquire respect pate heffa liam
thompson algertol
dr cortman scarlet the toasted chi
bang emperor taku spidey life tinel
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and yuno
and are pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
anatoly kazowski cricket xp
and day aura very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia
the red haired raven ted note 10
isparky65 fatboy games deadly saint and
soul rye slice and dice
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get a name featured
in future videos alongside these
amazing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link to that is in the
description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully already
destroyed so yeah you can support more
content now if you prefer
whichever way to support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you